every new year we love to look back on
what the previous year taught us and
this year is no exception so
on this episode we're jumping into part
two of the
lessons learned from 2020. if you're new
to the think marketing podcast
my name is heather torres and i just
want to welcome you
if you're one of our listeners over this
last year thank you so much for being a
part of our community and
just to let you know we do release a new
episode every single tuesday so make
sure you're subscribed wherever you're
consuming this content
from and this is again part two of the
two-part series where
sean is diving into some of the lessons
that we learned
here on youtube and also
through podcasting and what we've really
learned just in general
running a business online these are five
additional
uh lessons learned and what i love about
this session
is that sean really gets raw he
dives into some of the heart lessons
that were learned
during this pandemic during this season
of
uncertainty and i hope that you lean in
and while you're listening to these
different lessons i
would love for you to reflect on lessons
that you've learned
these are just our lessons and i think
it's really important that every year
you just audit what happened the
previous year so
let's get into today's episode
rise and grind it's a new year full of
new opportunities new possibilities
let's crush it sean cannell here and i
just want to wish you a happy new year
and say thank you so much for checking
out this episode
of the think marketing podcast i'm so
excited to get into part two
of 10 lessons i learned in 2020
that can help us have more success on
youtube in 2021 if you missed part one
that was the first five and i'm gonna
get into the second five
right now but i wanna thank you i wanna
thank you for spending your time
listening to this podcast whether you
watch it
or listen to it on youtube or whether
you're walking your dog
doing some chores you're at the gym i
just want to say i appreciate you i'm
grateful for you
and thank you for taking the time to
spend with heather taurus and myself and
the think media team
and taking the time to invest in
yourself we really believe
that the world needs leaders right now
the world needs educators like yourself
the world needs entertainers and the
world needs powerful content
that will make a difference in their
lives that'll help people solve problems
reach their ambitions and that's what
you're doing and we're here to help you
do that
more effectively on the think marketing
podcast you know 2020 taught us a lot of
things and
i know that it was a year that a lot of
people wanted to cancel
it was a hard year on many and so many
of us had so many different experiences
of course i think we all experienced
some suffering in a lot of ways
but also i think some of us found a lot
of blessings
hidden in that suffering maybe you lost
your job but you had more time
at home with your family maybe the
suffering was spending more time
at home with your family who knows i
mean we all had different
experiences but here are the second
five lessons that 2020 really taught us
and these are ones that i believe
are critical for having success
with youtube in 2021 and the first one
is double down on content
the lesson 2020 taught us that was a
successful lesson in terms of business
was doubling down on content and back in
march of 2020 once the lockdown was
announced once people started wondering
okay the economy is freezing
where you know restaurants are closing
shops are closing what are we going to
do
you need to stay at home order you need
to isolate
you know like anybody initially at thick
media
i mean we kind of panicked i mean i
think we kept our composure
but me as the ceo i was like what's
gonna happen what's the future of this
what's
what's gonna be going on and was
challenged and i talked about this
principle in the first episode
of you know shifting from peacetime
leadership to wartime leadership
and we decided to go on offense and as
content creators
what offense looks like is creating more
content
and so in 2020 all year long
we went from two to three videos a week
on think media to five videos a week now
keep in mind that's multiple content
creators
this started as just me shooting videos
in my bedroom by myself i've been
through every season i've been a solo
creator
now of course we've got omar and nolan
doing two videos a week each on think
media
you see we have a think media q a show
that is a monthly live stream
we have my friday uploads what are which
are repurposed
content there's a lot of different
things that i think we could go deeper
on
and a thinker in a future think
marketing podcast that would be helpful
but we doubled down on content i mean we
really
leaned in and then not only that we
committed to
every single tuesday coming bringing the
think marketing podcast to you
on audio and as a video podcast so on
youtube every tuesday
and we started a couple new shows the
coffee with kennel show
and the think marketing live show um
that also were
youtube live streams on the think
marketing channel so that's a ton of
content
now how could you apply this to your
life and business i think it's just to
ask yourself
are you being consistent with your
content how can you
create more content this year
not just content for content sake but
content that
attracts your ideal audience if you will
your ideal customer
and content that really solves problems
helps people reach their ambitions
and then can help people discover your
products programs and your
services it was a great year for us
on the other side of doubling down on
content lesson number two was double
down on community
and a couple ways we did that was from
the style
of content we were doing in addition to
starting a couple shows
we started the vra show and tony areola
vra stands for video ranking academy
he has a monthly show where he
interviews
somebody one of our students that's
crushing it on youtube getting results
with the program
and learns from them takes a few
questions more
time when we're locked down showing up
because we have tools
like zoom and stream yard to get on
camera
and connect with other people to get a
social interaction as best as can happen
if we're not allowed
to spend time with each other in person
we can lean in
to creating as much connection and
community as possible
so we really doubled down on community
we were kind of
practicing and we learned this lesson
that the business
that communicates the most wins the
business that is showing up the most
for the viewer for the audience
wins because a lot of people went into
waiting in retreat mode so we just
started showing up more
and by the way especially when the
lockdown happened
all my travel got cancelled i i wasn't
we we usually go to
washington to v visit our we live in
vegas now my wife sonia and i and our
son sean bradley
but because of the lockdown we weren't
going to washington so we found
that our schedule was reordered what did
we fill it with
not with just waiting not which is
pondering but we started posting more
content
so we started the coffee with kennel
show what was the purpose of the show
for one to two hours
sometimes three hours i bring people on
stream yard
and just answer questions back and forth
with the community that is not just
content because people can listen to
those conversations but it's also
as much as possible a chance to kind of
give back and connect with you
answer your questions and and try to get
to as many
individuals as possible to hear people's
stories hear what they're going
uh through and help for free right
on youtube with a live show called
coffee with kennel
heather taurus says the same thing on
the think marketing live show and
tony also has the tip of the week in vra
so here's the bottom line though the
principle
is how can you double down on community
how can you create
more touch points with your community
how can you maybe add something to your
schedule and take
a page out of our playbook here that's
maybe
a weekly show where you bring on one
guest you interview somebody from your
community you
you talk to one of your customers you
you bring them on your video podcast
and a tip could be to start a show and
we'll actually post a link in the show
notes of uh some training we have on
on why starting a signature show is a
really good idea
and when i say a show i mean coffee with
canal
is shot on a webcam with a usb mic
with stream yard it's pretty basic but
we just named it
claimed it picked a date calendared it
started doing it and for a while during
the 2020 year we did these every week
coffee with kennel and the think
marketing live show both happen every
single week
we eventually kind of reduced our
schedule for sustainability and
energy and now we alternate those shows
every other week and again that's
heather doing it myself doing it
point being is should you start a show
could you start a show could it be a q
a show could it be just another chance
for you to show up could it be
something where you bring people on and
you have conversations you have
discussions
you know we think about a tool like
stream yard and if you ever curious
about the tools that we use
at think media and think marketing we
have a page called
thinkmediatools.com and streamyard's one
of our favorites
um there's a discount if you want to get
access to the paid version it's our
favorite tool
for bringing multiple people on your
show i think their highest account now
allows at least six but they may have
bumped it to 10 people
that can actually be like if you want to
have kind of like a zoom call
but like nicer higher quality more
dynamic editing and different features
you can do looks better
that stream yard but any way you do it
you could use zoom
more conversation more community more
connection
think about starting a show and
additionally another huge lesson we
learned
with doubling down on community was we
did two challenges
and maybe you were a part let me know
whether uh you're able to leave a review
on
apple uh itunes and the podcast or if
you happen to be watching this on
youtube
have you been a part of one of our
challenges the youtube influence
challenge um you know we did those and
these were
seven days of giving free content
answering questions
of course we also let people know about
some of our advanced
programs and trainings and these were
very good
for our business in terms of sales and
things like that but they were also
great
at just connecting with people and
creating massive community we met people
doing these challenges were some of the
biggest brand growers awareness growers
meeting new people helping new people
maybe you're here maybe you discovered
this podcast because of one of those
challenges
doubling down on community this is your
chance in 2021
i think to think about how can i double
down on content and how can i do it
smart
and how can i double down on community
all right lesson number three
double down on personal growth man 2020
taught me
that i can either let all the negativity
and the vitriol and the toxic emotions
and the news cycle i could let this get
to me and really poison my heart and my
mind
or i could be really intentional and
remember that as proverbs says
guard your heart above all else because
out of it flows
all of the issues of life and 2020
taught me the importance
of doubling down on personal growth c.s
lewis said this
you can't go back and change the
beginning but you can
but you can start where you are and
change the ending
maybe you found yourself even going into
2021
like man i feel beat down
i feel in debt discouraged i feel really
set back
i can't go back and change the beginning
i can't change what happened last year
but you can start where you are right
now and you can still change the ending
and i felt this why in the road this
fork in the road and i feel like there
was
a lot of people in 2020 and it's a new
year it's a new opportunity to pick our
path
where we could stay in cycles of
potentially bitterness
stay in cycles of of maybe staying on
the couch
bottle of wine kind of ben and jerry's
and that extra season of whatever show
you're watching and by the way
we crushed a lot of tv in 2022 still we
still found a way to do it
but i saw i was like man i'm not going
to let 2020 get the best of me
and i'm applying the same thing in 2021
and i committed to a whole other level
of personal growth a few people on the
think media team
you know we're not like we just kind of
threw out this thing of this thing
called 75 heart by
andy furcella which is 75 days of
like a gallon of water a day a couple
workouts a day i didn't even finish it
shout out to jordan perez on the thick
media team
the one person who started on the think
media team that actually finished
what a legend what an icon absolute
respect
with three kids with think media with
life with church with everything that's
on her plate
pretty impressive you know when we did
our event growth video live i was about
33 days into it and then i was like
i i can't keep this thing going um and
uh and then i had a son and so it
seasons kind of shifted but here's what
happened
the habits i developed in doing half of
75 hard i just kept them going i was
like maybe i can't do two workouts a day
it's pretty intense
but pretty much i was able to go to a
baseline of one a day pretty much six to
seven days a week
wellness is the edge friend when you've
got a lot of emotional
and negativity and things you gotta find
a way to fight back keep your mind
strong keep your body strong
i really think it's just a lesson i
learned that doubling down on personal
growth
is more critical in times of uncertainty
toxic news you know emotional
being emotionally on edge and i think
2020 taught me too
that today's best will not meet
tomorrow's challenges
as we begin to especially as the
pandemic started
we began to feel so much uncertainty
like will we be in business tomorrow you
know as the ceo of think media i've got
payroll
for 12 people plus contractors 12 people
full time
and i start thinking man am i going to
be able to keep paying people
am i going to be able to uh are they
going to be able to feed their kids
based on
you start feeling a whole vortex of
emotions
so i felt a challenge of man my my best
today is not going to meet tomorrow's
challenges i've got to get better
and so in 2020 for me in response to
an uncertain future not knowing what
seeing some direct challenges
and also wondering what's around the
corner whether that's could be financial
cultural legal you know limitations
imposed by the government all kinds of
crazy things you don't really know
so it was a commitment to get better and
a lesson of
doubling down on personal
i love the quote that says the more you
sweat in peace
the less you bleed in war and you know
we might be in war right now and even in
2021
who knows it feels like maybe we've just
entered into a new dimension
of things just constantly being
uncertain
we got to get better we got to get
stronger we
got to double down and a book
recommendation is a book called
leadership by john maxwell and we'll
always link up those resources
in the show notes but a great book about
shifting and pivoting when crisis
and change and culture
and our organizations and youtube and
algorithms change
in 2020 and going into 2021 i'm more
committed than ever before
to sharpening my craft to studying
youtube
to working at my zone of genius to
leading this company to learning how to
be a better leader
to learning how to be a better content
creator to doubling down
on personal growth number four
teamwork makes the dream work
you've heard this before maybe uh famous
quote
somebody said but man it's so true
and teamwork makes the dream work
in so many different areas i think 2020
taught me
that man i can't succeed in this life
alone it's my belief that no man is an
island we need each other
i will admit i need other
people man i need my church family i
need my pastor
i need my wife i need to think media
team
i need my friends i need other people if
i'm going to stay healthy and strong and
navigate through things
and when there's a lot of pressure and
when there's uncertainty and when you
want to grow something
you need help i think about it in
business you got to get help
friend i want to challenge you this year
2021
commit to getting help will you say it
out loud wherever you are it's weird
you're you know you're driving and
someone's next to you like get help like
say like
i need help can you say that like repeat
after me i
need help now you might be like well i
haven't started making money on youtube
yet
you still got to get help and it could
just be communication with your partner
your sister
saying hey can you take the kids on
saturday morning so i can work on my
side hustle
you gotta get help can you help
alleviate this thing hey hey mom can you
take uh you know this aspect of my
schedule so that i could
accomplish this thing over here you
gotta ask for help
you gotta maybe hire a virtual assistant
you can check out
you know maybe hire an editor vid chops
is a nice
affordable relatively speaking video
editing service
you can check that out at
thinkmediatools.com and that's getting
help so that you're maybe outsourcing
video editing
for us at think media one of the reasons
why i think
that we weren't able to just survive in
2020 but able to thrive
in 2020 was because of the team there's
no question about it
i am surrounded by some of the most
world-class
generous humble giving skilled
individuals
that are willing to also make sacrifices
to commit to these same standards of
personal growth and
committing to sacrifice and community
and content
this industry is challenging especially
when
the world feels like it's melting all
around you and in a way it is
so teamwork makes the dream work think
about how you're going to build your
team
when i was a solo creator for so many
years
i i said things about myself like i'm
just not good at delegating
maybe you'd say these same things i just
don't know where i'd find people
i just don't know how i could afford it
i just don't think i'd ever be able to
do that i'm just going to find out a way
to do it by myself
but my friend i want to challenge you to
just commit to the idea that you need
help
and for me i got a book by brian tracy
like an audiobook like
how to delegate i started to like read
on the skill i wanted to grow in
for years i listened to podca i studied
i just was like i need to set that as a
target even if it's not tomorrow
i'm gonna need to get help for the scale
and the vision and where this all this
thing is gonna go
no question i learned more than ever
before that teamwork makes the dream
work
and it's not just business that's true
in life as well i'm learning that it
takes a village to raise a child right
we have a brand new son and we just
think we're so blessed
and privileged for kind of this
synergistic
loving incredible community that's
building here in vegas
and i recognize there's been seasons
where we felt isolated disconnected in a
different city without much of a friend
group or network and i'm empathetic to
whatever your situation might be
but i want to encourage you to look for
find a community to connect with
because you need a team in life a team
to to help
you know if you just get stuck in your
own thoughts and you can't bounce those
thoughts off anybody else
you got to talk things out you got to
process issues
so just having a team in life has been
critical we survived 2020 and i believe
thrived in 2020
because of the community around us the
team around us
and then the family team as well you
know most of our family
lives a state away a couple states away
up in washington state while we live in
nevada
but even still leaning in on family and
we consider
the think media team family in different
aspects
teamwork makes the dream work you got to
build your team
you got to commit to building your team
for me i prayed to build my team
god help me find a team help me find a
crew help me find a community help me
find a tribe
help me find a group to do life together
with
help me find in my belief and you know
we respect any
belief here at think media but uh we are
i'm a christian and uh i
i believe that being connected to a
local church
is critical to just surviving in life
like i i
i need it i believe that god designed us
to be in community
to where we're being encouraged each
week where we get to worship each week
and where we get to be in community and
so i'm so
grateful for city light church here in
las vegas
and man i wouldn't have got through
2020. even when we just could watch
online
because teamwork makes
the dream work finally lesson number
five
of part two and if you missed part one
definitely check that out on the podcast
go back on the youtube channel or
spotify or apple and
let me know what was a lesson you
learned in 2020 good or bad
something 2020 taught you but a lesson
and a learning that you extrapolated
from the year
post that in the comments but number
five
count your blessings and keep things in
perspective you know
with everything that's going on i've
learned this no matter what situation
you're in
sony and i have been months away from
being zero in our bank account and even
going bankrupt
we've lost homes we've been under
massive uh
health challenges and sonya has
continually battled a chronic illness
you know i think even some of the
strength and fortitude
that i felt in 2020 is because i had my
2020 back in 20
in 2009 i mean we experienced
financial devastation health devastation
with my wife almost
dying our community falling apart our
whole church community and our friend
group all melting all around us
because of some bad decisions by a few
people that reverberated through our
whole church community
we had a chance to actually let 2009
cause us to get bitter
cause us to get sidelined cause us to
give up
give in or just move us to inaction but
we learned some of these lessons that
now a decade later they're even stronger
in my life
and i think that has really helped us
navigate this year
but one of the biggest lessons was that
whether you're in the hardest of times
or even the best of times you still got
to count your blessings
i like to start my day sometimes when
i'm feeling a little off
and i just go to my journal and i just
write down things i'm grateful for
big or small and i just like to count
my blessings and keep things in
perspective
when i think about how 2020 hit people
so hard in so many different ways
again maybe we had to stay home and
maybe depending on where you live
you had different limitations in a city
or different things but even as i was
like shoot we can't visit our family in
washington
we started to do other things and one of
the things we learned in 2020 was
going on a lot of hikes with my wife
sonia because we're like we got nothing
else to do we're not even allowed to see
the think media team or friends in the
city or anything else
so like every single weekend for the
entire lockdown
i went on more hikes with my wife sonia
in during the pandemic when it first
started than we had in our entire 15
years of marriage
and what's crazy is that that it became
a habit and now it's something that
is almost a weekly occurrence for us
it's it's transformed our health
it's transformed our relationship it's
transformed
my stress levels because man who would
have thought if you get off your phone
and get into nature
and disconnect and exercise and breathe
fresh air for a few hours
away from everything at least like once
a week what that would do for
i mean it kind of makes sense but again
even in the midst
of the crisis there was this seed of
opportunity
to spend more time and really strengthen
our marriage and now even spend time
with our new son time resting and
recovering
i think a lot of us learned that the
pandemic gave us a pause
it had to slow down depending on our
schedules and
and you can look at it as like man i
lost my job or you could look at it as
it's time to reinvent myself
it's time to reflect and time to think
about my next moves
and for me i was traveling so much and i
was probably going at a pace that
at least was quite grueling if not
a little too much and i found that wow
margin is healthy time for rest and
recovery margin to read and learn
i realized that the pace i was going and
even the way and a lot of it was so many
good things so many just different
invites from friends to speak at events
and
be a part of different things and so
falling back in love
really with reading starting 75 hard and
starting to dive into
books again and it bringing a whole
another level of
stimulating my mind and bringing me to
an elite level of thinking and
really giving me some margin to dream
even during really hard times
and we watched a lot of great shows i
tell you what like if you want to talk
about the record holder
for spending the most money per month on
digital streaming services my wife sony
and i
for sure have i mean amazon prime that
one's fair because that's the free
shipping
hbo max yeah raised by wolves we had to
you know stars
because of the seduce the nixium call
you don't even really want to go there
but it's pretty interesting
you know hbo max has the vow on it as
well i mean
netflix of course uh hulu
you know you're like what yeah and then
disney plus
basically all of them and what happens
is you know
we really only like to watch like the
best of the best of the best shows and
then we'll be like well that's on a
platform we don't even have
next thing you know we're signing up and
then i'm like honey we'll just
cancel it after the cancellation period
we forget to do that
and so we just took out a loan in order
to pay our monthly um
uh you know stream i'm just kidding
right but but we were able to watch a
lot of
a lot of great shows and you might be
like i feel the same way i finished
netflix in 2020. i mean i didn't just
watch i finished the whole platform
with a vpn counting all the options in
other countries come on stick with me
and so you know count your blessings
though and keep things in perspective
there was so many things we couldn't do
literally our schedule got changed
plans we had got cancelled things had to
be rearranged
but we pivoted our plan you can either
pivot or you can panic
and we pivoted and we're counting our
blessings the memories we
made the time that we got to spend with
each other keeping things in perspective
and you know i love this quote
that uh i'm reminded of that's actually
in the book of
corinthians in the in the new testament
and it says that these light and
momentary troubles
are nothing compared to the surpassing
glory that awaits us
and you know as i kind of land the plane
on this one when i think about counting
your
blessings and keeping things in
perspective for me just being real and
raw with you
as a person of faith it helped me just
reframe
because you got to know i got a lot of
fears like
god what does the future hold for my son
sean bradley like what's the economy
going to be like
what's our country going to be like what
does the future hold
for our team what is even if maybe we
are able to pivot and adapt to this
what's the future of youtube i mean i'm
just like you worried
you know about the future about what's
gonna happen next about
are my parents gonna be okay i hope are
they you know are they gonna get this
thing like
what's going on but i have to be
reminded
that as a person of faith and as a
christian my belief is that if i'm
right with god if i'm right with my
family
my goal in life is to steward the time
that i have here
to steward my time my talents and my
treasures
and there was 20 20 challenged me
to lean deeper into my faith and into
prayer
to say man my attachment with open hands
is not really to this life uh as a
believer i believe
in the life to come and that whether
i've got
a day left on this planet or i've got a
year left or i've got a hundred years
left
i'm just here to steward my time be
faithful
i want to live up to my god-given
potential to love my wife
hopefully do well by the team in my life
you know honor god with my time and
honor
god with my uh my heart and all those
things and so
learning and trying to cultivate an
anchored faith
of man even if everything's falling
apart around me
not everything has to be falling apart
within me and 2020 was a chance
and a challenge to have inner peace
cultivated which i think is critical for
maybe what's to come in 2021
an uh an inner peace an inner confidence
an inner health an inner calm
to take on whatever is to come and to
face every challenge and to try to be
as much as and we all fail we all fall
but to
to try to realize man i want to be
strong for those around me i want to be
strong for the team i want to be strong
for my son's looking up to me now
you know all those different things and
2020 was a chance to keep things in
perspective that look
man especially here and i'm we live in
america i'm like man
kind of first world problems i'm not
trying to minimize the pandemic
but like man if i'm right with god like
i've learned the secret of being content
in
any in all circumstances i could do all
things through christ who strengthens me
if i'm right with my family man if my if
my family respects me and and things are
going well with sonia i mean
we fight and uh there's days when maybe
things are not going well
with sonia but when i think about on the
big scale
the strength of our marriage and what we
fought for and gone through counseling
for
and where we fought to get to my
definition of success i stole from john
maxwell that at the end of my
life if the people closest to me
love and respect me the most i've won
it's not about the youtube subscribers
or a gold play button or a silver play
button
if at the end of my life the people
closest to me love and respect me the
most i've won
doesn't matter how much is in the bank
account i would like there to be more in
the bank account than less
but that's not what matters that it's
just my conduct and my
character that i believe matters overall
and 2020 was sure a chance
to if you will strengthen our character
so i hope these points serve you going
into 2021
double down on content double down on
community double down on personal growth
lifelong leaders are lifelong learners
keep learning double down on team
commit to getting help you need help i
need help we all need help
in all areas of our life we cannot do
this alone or go very far
on our own and then keep things in
perspective count your blessings in the
entire process i really believe it's
less about the destination
and it's more about the journey and so
commit to the journey
count your blessings keep things in
perspective and buckle your seatbelt
because 2021 we've got an unreal plan
an unreal year of content planned for
you on the think marketing podcast
so thanks for listening to these lessons
check out part one and now let me kick
it back to heather
[Music]
wow those ten lessons over the last
episode and this episode
were so impactful i love how sean shares
his heart
and his faith and really just dives into
what it means to be a leader
what it means to be someone who is
trying to grow
online and i hope that this brings some
relatability to what you're doing
i think these lessons are lessons that
we've kind of all learned and it's
really good reminder to
just take that audit of what happened
the year before
have a place like a journal or a google
doc where you're
recording these different things that
are happening throughout the year
we here at think call it our victory log
now i know we have these 10 lessons that
you learned over the last episode in
this episode
but throughout the year if you're just
keeping track of some of the
victories that are happening some of the
small wins and some of the big wins
i think it'll help you when you go back
to reflect on the year to remember
all of the things that have happened the
good the bad the ugly
but really the last one that sean said
were the blessings
knowing that we are so blessed to be
able to bring content like this
that you are so blessed to be able to
bring content to your audience
this is awesome and so i just want to
thank you so much for being a part of
the think community
and if you've not actually rated and
reviewed the podcast
that probably is your next step after
you're done listening to this one
we love to read the reviews that you're
leaving over
on apple itunes and really what does it
do well when you rate and review the
podcast with us
it allows itunes to put this podcast in
front of
other people just like you who are
wanting to grow on
youtube and today's review comes from
echo
and it says no joke it's that good
everything
is well executed the sound quality is on
point with thoughtful and enriching
questions echo i'll make sure to tell
our team who loves audio about that
comment
you also said i am for it i want more of
it
if you're not convinced check out the
think media youtube channel that has
over a million subscribers and
endless high quality content it will
alter
your flip cam experience no joke
best for entrepreneurs and people that
want to tap into the youtube vault
of passive income or just express
themselves better
using video and online marketing happy
listening wow what a great review
and i would love to read your review on
a future episode so make sure you go
over
rate and review the podcast today and
this episode was brought to you by the
think master class if you're ready to go
deeper on youtube if this is your year
to start
or grow your channel or if you are ready
to get serious
about growing your channel then you
should watch
our youtube class you can go to
thinkmasterclass.com
that's where you can register for this
free one-hour class that sean cannell
shares
where he gives the three secrets to
youtube success
he dives into what's working right now
how youtube has
changed and what you need to know to be
successful on this platform
this year this is a one hour class that
you can take on your iphone
tablet you can listen to it while you're
driving or on your computer
but i recommend taking it in a
distraction free zone
where you can be honed in on this one
hour class where sean's delivering free
content that he normally teaches
inside of our paid academy you can go
there right now at
thinkmasterclass.com register for that
class and then throughout this year
we're going to be sending you more
information through email
so that you can stay up to date with
what's happening all over
think i want to thank you again for
being a part of our community
thank you for leaning in for listening
for being an
action taker that's who we know our
community is and i'm so grateful that
you're here
i'm excited for future episodes like
sean said we have some power packed
content coming your way and i can't wait
for you to hear more on the think
marketing podcast
[Music]
you